as critical race theory faces
ever-mounting criticism the strategy of
its proponents is to start throwing mud
in the water
they can't stand by their real beliefs
or defend what they're actually doing
so instead they try to turn the
discussion about critical race theory
into something else entirely we've
talked about that already but the
the efforts are getting more and more
desperate so henry rogers
stage name ibram x candy uh went on
msnbc yesterday and claimed
that he doesn't believe that white
people are inherently racist let's
listen to that
do you believe that white americans are
inherently racist
oh i do not and indeed in how to be an
anti-racist
i make the case that we shouldn't
believe that anyone
is inherently racist or that we should
identify
anyone as a racist whoa
what we shouldn't identify anyone as a
racist well that's
that's news to everyone including to
henry rodgers himself who
not long ago was saying stuff like this
it is critical for for white people for
people
uh in general to stop denying
their their racist ideas to stop denying
the ways in which policies have
benefited them to stop denying
their racism and to realize that
actually the heartbeat of racism itself
is denial and the sound of that
heartbeat is i'm not racist
uh okay so white people aren't
inherently racist
and we shouldn't call people racist but
at the same time white people need to
stop denying that they're racist
and when they deny that they're racist
it only proves
that they're racist this would seem to
be a rather
confusing set of ideas until you realize
that it's not a set of ideas at all
there are no set ideas the ideas and
claims change in order to accommodate
the rhetorical needs of the moment
fortunately for mr rogers he feels no
moral obligation to be honest he has a
moral obligation to be honest same as
anyone else
but he doesn't feel it being a
congenital liar at all
another strategy is to change the
subject and pretend
that the argument is about something
else entirely it's to pretend that the
people opposed to critical race theory
education
are really opposed to education in
general
so i thought this is a great example of
this strategy this is a video of a
teacher
offering a response to critical race
theory critics
and she kind of demonstrates this
approach let's uh let's listen to that
a response to republicans whenever you
say we should teach about slavery or the
genocide of indigenous people in the
classroom
is oh what happened so long ago why do
we have to why do we why they need to
know why does anyone need to know
okay why do you learn about the
holocaust why do you learn about the
rwandan genocide
why do you learn about imperialism why
do you learn about the enlightenment why
do you learn about the soviet union
why do you know about the american
revolution why are you learning about
the civil war
all those things were in the past why
why do we learn about them
it's it's almost as though
there's a class you take in school
where you talk about things that
happened in the in the past
wait a minute wait this is all making
too much sense right it's too much
no got to say
see-through shirt interesting choice for
the classroom
uh but look i don't mean to pick on this
one teacher i do mean to pick on her
actually but not just her
this is a common enough talking point to
warrant a thorough response i think the
claim
is that republicans and by that she
means anyone who's not firmly and
totally on her ideological side on every
issue
are opposed to kids being taught about
slavery or the quote genocide of native
americans
and that we don't want these things
taught because they happened a long time
ago and therefore nobody needs to know
the problem with the argument as she
presents it is that literally
not one single person has ever made that
argument she's the first one to make it
nobody and i really do mean nobody is
suggesting that the
fact of american slavery should not be
taught
i have not heard anyone say that
and i would defy anyone to provide an
example of anyone saying that
it'd be quite convenient if we would
make that argument because it's a very
stupid
argument and easy to debunk but that's
not the argument
so since she brought up the subject let
me now um explain
and this is all very tied into the to
the critical race theory discussion
especially as the proponents try to
change the subject
um so so let me explain
what our point as it pertains to slavery
actually is and really there are two
points and they're both rather simple
one the full story
and truth about slavery should be taught
if we're going to tell kids about
slavery and we should
then we need to give them the complete
picture so far from wanting nothing
taught about slavery
we actually want more to be taught about
it
we want more said we want more time
spent on it the fact that so many
americans think slavery is a uniquely
white sin
and that white americans carry some kind
of special guilt for it only shows that
the education they're being given about
slavery
is narrow and incomplete we want to
widen the lens
expand the scope of the discussion
consider these questions how many
americans know
that slavery was still practiced legally
in africa as recently as 1980.
if you're in my generation my generation
was
walking this earth or at least crawling
on it um
at a time when there was still legal
slavery in the world in africa how many
americans know that
how many realize that it was practiced
legally all across the non-western world
long after it had been abolished
everywhere in the western world
how many realize that it still goes on
unofficially
quote unquote in africa the mideast and
asia
how many even realize that slavery is an
ancient institution which predates the
formation of the united states by many
thousands of years
how many know that by the time white
americans were buying slaves
the practice had already been in place
in the middle east for 8
000 years how many know that it had been
going on for thousands of years in the
americas before the white man showed up
how many know that black americans and
native americans
both owned black slaves
i think the answer on all counts is very
few
very few people in this country know any
of those facts
i believe they should know those facts
which means that i want far
more to be taught about slavery my
problem with the slavery education being
provided
by women like the one in that video is
that it doesn't go nearly far enough
do any of the facts i just listed
minimize
the objective evil of american slavery
no
do they potentially mitigate the
personal moral culpability of the
individuals in this country who
supported it or practiced it
yes of course i mean someone who
practiced slavery today
someone who practices slavery today and
again people do practice it today
is more morally culpable than someone
who practiced it 200 years ago
the fact that slavery was an accepted
institution the world over for thousands
and thousands of years
everywhere does not again make it less
objectively evil but it does call for
the actions of the individuals
who are involved in it to be judged
within their historical context
and and uh and yet none of that is
really the point
we should teach the full truth about
slavery simply because it's the full
truth
when we teach kids about science or
technology or mathematics
do we pretend that all of those things
were invented by and started with white
americans
do we tell kids in school that americans
invented democracy or poetry or
literature
no you see when it comes to the good
things the things of value
we make sure that our children know that
other people throughout history and
around the world contributed
and yet with slavery we tend to take all
the credits
funny how that works isn't it that's our
first point about slavery the second
is that no person living today
should be made to feel any guilt at
all for atrocities that happened before
they were born
slavery included and this is a really
fortunate thing because there's a very
good chance
that all of us every person alive today
is descended from slave owners at some
point back in their family tree
now i know that i'm not descended from
white american slave owners
my family got here after
that was all done but uh but
some far-removed relative way back there
my lineage
probably owned some slaves somewhere at
some point
that's true for you too it's true for
everyone black white or otherwise
you've also most likely had relatives
who murdered who robbed who committed
other unknown acts of savagery
the world is a brutal place today and it
used to be a whole lot more brutal
nobody's ancestral line is pure or clean
so
we can all be weighed down by guilt for
things we didn't do and had no hand in
and which occurred before we even
existed or we can carry on with our
lives
i suggest the latter in fact i don't
think
that you should even necessarily be
weighed down by guilt for things
that you did do if you did something bad
and you feel guilty as you should um
then make amends the best you can
apologize to the person you wrong
repent of your sins change your ways
make your act of contrition but there's
nothing to be gained
no virtue to be found in walking around
every day utterly obsessed with
and possessed by the sins of your past
for which you've already repented
and here i refer again to the sins of
your past
even those should not consume you
but the sins of someone else's past sins
in which you played
absolutely no part whatsoever
if you feel guilt about that then your
situation is uh pathological
and those are my points about slavery
i think i can generally speak for for
all conservatives really
on this this is what we're saying about
slavery
yes teach about it but teach the right
things
teach the full picture and don't cast
blame where it doesn't belong
that's it pretty simple well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt well
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content